الماءَ يَرُشُ دو دو دو دو دو
في الحَمَّامِ دو دو دو دو دو
يَرُشُ يَرُشُ دو دو دو دو دو كالأمطار
أَغْسِلُ جِسْمِى دو دو دو دو دو
بالصَّابون دو دو دو دو دو
رَائِحَتِي  دو دو دو دو دو كالأزهار
أَغْسِلُ شَعْرِى   دو دو دو دو دو
بِالشَّامْبو   دو دو دو دو دو
وعَيْنِي دو دو دو دو دو أغمضها
الماءُ جميل  دو دو دو دو دو
أَغْسِلُ قَدَمي   دو دو دو دو دو
ووَجْهِي دو دو دو دو دو كَالكِبارْ
بَطَتِيَ   دو دو دو دو دو
تَسْبَحُ  دو دو دو دو دو
وباخِرَتي دو دو دو دو دو أَنا البَحَّار
بالصَّابون دو دو دو دو دو
أَغْسِلُ  دو دو دو دو دو
تُفْلِتُ دو دو دو دو دو تَنْزَلِقُ
حَوْلي الرَغْوَة  دو دو دو دو دو
فُقَّاعاتْ   دو دو دو دو دو
تَلْمَع  دو دو دو دو دو في كُلِ مَكان
الدُشُ يَرُشْ دو دو دو دو دو
الماءُ دو دو دو دو دو
مُنْعِشٌ دو دو دو دو دو أَنا مَسْرور
بَعْدَ الحَمْامْ     دو دو دو دو دو
أُجَفِفْ  دو دو دو دو دو
بِالفوطَة  دو دو دو دو دو
فَأَبْدو كَالأَميرْ